Yeah,
I first and foremost a Christian.
And that means not only that I draw my
inspiration from the Bible,
but also for me.
I'm an Orthodox Christian,
so it's also from the great creed,
the apostles,
creed,
and so on.
Um,
and that is a bedrock for my life.
I,
and I wouldn't say that I'm a great
Christian in the sense that I can always
do what I think are what to do,
but I tend to,
I once read a book,
uh,
by an episcopal done.
Yes,
there are fiscal sponsor and what
triggered what sort of government,
episcopal nun who said that,
um,
you can't see the future and it's,
you can't tell what God wants to do five
years from now,
but if you look carefully,
we take the time to get general,
tell what you're supposed to do right
now.
Uh,
and I try to think of things that way.
I try to think about what I should do
right now.
I tend to be a thoughtful person.
I tend to be someone.
I don't make snap judgments.
I like to take time to think things
over.
Um,
and then want to make decisions.
I tend to stick to them but they tend to
be social.
I made over a period of time.
We live in a world that encourages snap
judgments,
that rewards thinking fast and I don't
think that makes for very good decision.
Making.
My wife I should say is also a great
inspiration to me.
Um,
uh,
my wife is not only a Christian but
someone who tries to live our faith and
really thinks very hard about the right
thing to do.
She currently is involved in issues that
I think are of great importance.
She's apprentice lawyer as I am.
She's working with Jones defense one as
well as being corporate law.
Before that she now affiliated with a
couple of think tanks and she's
interested in the future of mothering
in,
in America and in the world.
And she's interested in the
commodification of children in two
senses.
Both the,
the,
the sense in which we might say the
commercialization of childhood
advertising aimed at children trying to
create little consumers and also
commodification of different sense of
the notion of designer babies.
And what does that say about humanity,
about us,
and about our future?
She doesn't go into these things as a
shrill advocate.
She goes to these things to try to
understand the direction we're moving
and to try to encourage conversations
about these directions.
What I like about her approach is
exactly that,
that she wants to encourage conversation
when she wants to do is create a world
which people think about issues and then
talk about them as opposed to go on
television.
You rant and rave about them.
I think that's the kind of work that I
wish more advocates would do.
It's kind of work that I used to
[inaudible].